vous êtes la crème de l'
aristocratie française et l'envie de tous les tribunaux
d'Europe quand je regarde je vois la corruption les
ténèbres la tentation le meurtre
j'ai passé des heures je dois revenir avec
un vos relations continues avec l'
Amérique contractent une dette et le
compte n'est pas  pourtant payé soit ceux-
ci m'excitent souvent contre les menaces du
potentiel extérieur je
remets en question les ombres à côté du changement
sous moi j'avais un coup de main oui je sais comment je
vois que c'était alors mal interprété le
rôle de manager doit être mis au courant mais ils doivent
garder leur avis romain de toutes les affaires
je  dit que tu es allé à Waddle pour me combattre
mais nous allons prendre le Messie pour
venir
et pourtant la contagion se propage c'est
dans mon mur c'est dans mon sang
est-ce étonnant que je n'ai pas dormi
attraper des chimies occasionnelles précises
même descendre bas  à la durée encore plus même pas
dit ma
vous